in the last video we worked out the step
response of an rc circuit and now we're
going to look at a real example
so so this is our answer this is the
step response the total response to our
circuit to a step input
and what does this look like so i'm
going to move down a little bit
we'll make up a circuit and we'll do a
real example here
let's say we do a step and the step goes
from
0.2 volts
up to
say 1.1 volts
and let's let r equal 1 k ohm
k ohm
and let the capacitor equal
4
microfarads
so now let's plug these values over here
into our solution and see what we get
now first i'm going to work out rc
rc is equal to 1
k ohm
times 4
microfarads and what does that equal
k is plus 3
and micro is minus six so one times four
is four
and plus three minus six is times ten to
the minus
three
and that is in seconds so that's equal
to 4
milliseconds
now let's plug the rest of our values in
here
v of t
the total response or the step response
equals
v naught 0.2
minus
v s that's the step voltage 1.1
times
e
to the minus
t over
4 milliseconds
plus
vs plus vs vs is 1.1
so i went ahead and i plotted this on
using a computer
and we'll see how close this comes to
what we sketched earlier
so here's here's vt
or the step response the total response
of us of our rc network to a step
voltage
the step voltage is here in in rows
color
and it goes from 0.2 volts up to
oh i got it wrong
1.2 volts let's change that to the right
number
1.2
1.2
and this is what it looks like and if
you go back and compare this to what we
saw what we sketched at the beginning
it'll look pretty similar so the output
voltage the voltage on the capacitor
here
starts at v naught which is 0.2
it ends up at v s
which is 1.2 in this case and that's the
forced response up here and in between
it did that smooth exponential curve
that's what the step response of an rc
circuit looks like